royaume de dreamland droit devant elle
est toute petite scène il c'est parce
que je suis le comment vous le trouvez
méchamment les chais pour faire ma
toilette deux fois
on va faire un tour du monde ou personne
s'en est jamais plaint et à l'eau
aromatisée au vieux péché que rien ne
doit avoir peur ou pas je vous sens
quelque peu à peu alors là on a wire de
pouce ou là il ya un gros show valait
vous la légendaire vierge de fer et
enfin le recueil de blagues de beaucoup
vous avez devant vous le seul ennemi
puis si j'en ai rien à secouer déjà trop
tard je suis pas un chat moi je suis
plutôt moi je voudrais savoir quand vos
maladies et les épidémies disparaîtront
pour les remplacer par les plus
mortelles c'est tout le monde dit si tu
dors pas 72 heures défilent et a toutes
les chances de devenir sablé alors faut
se lever la taille
les fêtes sont les outils servant à
acheter la paix sociale qui produiront
au cours issement et à l'effondrement de
la civilisation
allez on tape dans nos moeurs
[Musique]
la tonne fatigue
nous passons notre vie à inventer de
nouvelles batteries j'ai envie de
découvrir le moyen d'écouté vendre votre
maison de la cave au grenier c'est fou
vous puissiez vous retenir on a un petit
penchant pour la firme de crewe
c'est rigolo la guerre mais j'aurais pas
jusqu'à dire que j'aime ça
hop
du courage et tu sais que si tu crois en
toi rien ne pourra être fait rechuter
et vous arrêtez changer de modèle une
rose aussi délicat que vous n'êtes pas à
sa place à ben de marrant je vous en
prie un jour j'arriverai à contrôler mon
destin tu crois pas qu'on veut tous tout
faire pour essayer de partir et de
découvrir qui on est vraiment je te
promet aussi que j'arrête de picoler
mais qu'est ce que tu as dans la main
gauche d'où elle sort celle là j'ai le
choix entre marié et mourir ça risque
d'être un choix encore plus difficile
vous êtes par la présente conviés aux
épousailles royal du prince 10 baer de
bons tours et de la princesse been
désirez vous êtes reprises devant nous
tous par cet homme comme épouse non
[Musique]
c'est effrayant c'est pas le moment de
commencer à cogiter sur tout ça ça se
passe comment
un jour j'arriverai à contrôler mon
destin j'ai envie de découvrir le monde
moi je voudrais savoir quand vos
maladies et les épidémies disparaîtront
pour les remplacer par les plus mortels
depuis été ingérable
j'ai même plus de quoi hurler suis pas
si horrible
ben tu as quand même tué ce type là mais
je ne veux pas si mal que ça il faudrait
que de bonnes âmes tirent la tête dame
d'ailleurs si tu crois pas qu'on veut
tous à un moment de notre vie tout faire
pour essayer de partir et de découvrir
qui on est vraiment quoi je crois que je
suis une bonne bouche r je vends des
animaux de compagnie
c'est bizarre ce que je ressens plus
aucune envie de me bourrer la gueule
c'est l'espoir
très mauvaise idée qu'est ce que la
mauvaise mais ce combat j'ai compris
je suis vraiment fier de toi wok et moi
je suis un mec
souvenez vous que le seul truc efficace
pour pas se laisser entraîner vers la
cascade c'est de nager à contre-courant
en d'accord t'as du courage et tu sais
que si tu crois en toi rien ne pourra le
faire chuter
[Musique]